des fans conquis le site de Salins était
plein à craquer hier soir durant 75
minutes et pas une de plus la Belge
Angèle récite mécaniquement ses tubes et
interdiction formelle de filmer la diva
pas d'interview avec la presse pas de
balance devant les bénévoles pas de
rencontre avec les Réunionnais il
fallait être sur place pour ressentir le
chaud
c'est incroyable genre vraiment waouh
une expérience magnifique Angèle
toujours autant la femme fatale qu'elle
est elle était incroyable elle était
magnifique en fait Angel elle défend
beaucoup de causes et je trouve que
c'est bien je serais peut-être pas trop
objectif mais c'était trop millimétré à
mon goût à mon goût oui pourquoi parce
que ça se voit on est pas bête c'est il
y avait aucun écart tout était parfait
c'était 100% la perfection voilà
Bruxelles je t'aime balance ton quoi
démon ta reine la popstar livre un balai
précis peut-être trop pour beaucoup
c'était pas terrible mais j'ai quand
même kiffé Angèle les gens de chez nous
donc on est hyper attaché à elle je suis
assez déçu parce que c'est comme
d'habitude le chaud est millimétré on
s'attend qu'un c'est trop lisse en fait
mais voilà il manque ce petit truc de la
Belgique justement où il y a un manque
de de Flo un manque de punch un manque
d'énergie tu vois la tente espérer
histoire d'amour contre la chanteuse et
la Réunion n'aura pas lieu Angèle qui
tralal comme elle est venue emprisonnée
dans sa tour d'ivoire